- Le gouverneur républicain
de l'État de la Floride promet
que ce n'est pas terminé.
"Toutes les villes devraient
se partager ce fardeau;
il ne devrait pas tomber
uniquement sur le dos
des États républicains."
Une cinquantaine de migrants
vénézuéliens ont été envoyés
sur l'île cossue de Martha's
Vineyard, un bastion démocrate,
prisé par l'élite politique
américaine.
Le gouverneur De Santis
a lui-même affrété les vols
à partir du Texas.
"Le trajet a été tellement
long, il nous a fallu un mois
pour traverser le Mexique.
Enfin, nous sommes rendus",
explique ce Vénézuelien
d'origine.
Après avoir été accueillis par
des travailleurs communautaires,
les autorités ont annoncé
que les migrants seront
finalement transférés
sur une base militaire.
Depuis des mois,
des ténors républicains,
comme le gouverneur du Tasas,
font transporter des migrants
dans des États démocrates
pour dénoncer les politiques
migratoires de Joe Biden.
La tension a ntnté d'un cran
dans les derniers jours
quand d'autres réfugiés
ont été envoyés tout près
de la résidence de la vice-
présidente Kamala Harris.
"Je pense que c'est vraiment
le bordel. C'est vraiment
horrible la façon dont
ils utilisent les gens
comme des pions."
"Il y avait plus de
journalistes à Martha's Vineyard
qu'il n'y en a jamais eu au sud
de la frontière. Vous devriez
vous y rendre afin de constater
ce qui se passe!"
La Maison-Blanche
dénonce ce qu'elle qualifie
de mise en scène, alors que
les républicains espèrent que
la question soit un des thèmes
centraux lors de l'élection
de mi-mandat.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Montréa